前回のあらすじ多治見冊は乳業全部とずで売ると言い出して
たくさんのカードの値段を知らせてチェックリストにカードを書くことによって
11時間の時間がかかって心身共に疲れたらその日のうちにカードを売りに行った
しかしカード量が多すぎで査定にすごい時間がかかったのでその日の夜に
また査定で9もらえるのかっていうのを知ることになりましたので今はしばらく
中継車
time そしてこの後編からはその過程でわかった金額がわかるようになる動画で
ございますみなさんお楽しみに
yeah
決まったいいん
ええっ
voodoo ん
うん
夜になりましたね無事に系のお店からは終わりましたさてが降りましたというお話を
いただいたのでもう1回お店に行ってたして買い取るの金属はいくらだったのかを今
から見に行きますまずは一展望名まずその脳までカードとかちょっとしたでやカード
いった安い方のお店からまず
てみたいと思います安いほうでしょ水帆
託そうとつかないんだけどまぁ
まあ一番つければいいじゃないと多分一番くらいかなと思ってるんですけど
この企画が始まってもうすぐ24時間が経とうとしております
いかに高く売れるか僕が持ってた宝の山は何円だったのでしょうか
つきました1軒目のお店です
ん
では
てますえっ
きたん
ません
オーダーこそ
4それじゃないいやすごいよほんと全部見てくれたみたいで
金額がちゃんとバッジになっておりますそこそこいろんなカードを買ってくるって
ブレイクするスキルのしか900円で倒れもう金額の方へ行けますかそうか1店舗目の
金額
はい
4万個
4万765m サイバーううっ ok
すげーリッターで4万どんどん4万だよ
じっくり人に塗らないカードうまいことさばいたんだよっちゃんヌードル
第本命はこの次のお店ですチェックリストを入れて次が多分めちゃくちゃ高いと思われ
ます
インタビューを見ていきましょう
まあ正直出雲とかもあるんでジュマンが順にぐらいじゃんその行こう
ええええええ
じゃまたん
入っていきますはっはっは
木桶でムーン
tee
me
買取すればいっ
あいつらだけだ際はリーマンだと思います
me
car
が入って大丈夫ですか
あっほんとですかーはジャンプ制コレかさが最高エアーラードでますご静聴ありがとう
ございますどうぞよろしくお願いします
2ん
e 4の
定員さん要求過去最高金額
なるほど自己最高金額過去最高枚数の自著
みますかこの回1尾作って
文化ぬ
めっ泣きそんでね今まで行っ
お金だけじゃねーじゃんうわぁで動いたりさ調べたりさん
それが全部含めてこの金額だったらって思ったよねんか
良い木尾根が4回見入ったでねこれが
僕が
今までしてきた
決勝です
220,000うわーっ5000円超えすだれ
なかったかった
こんな感じですね952前で22万5000
このッパたお餅食ってから米呼ばずでこれとさっきの店舗のやつを合わせますと
癒すこれ予想の遥か上でしょというわけ
僕がすべての影響カード売った結果合計金額
206万6300円でございました
4 o
a 大事なものを失った気がするあのあの量だとさ
1 by 晒すのでますよ次の時間に見つかるレベルじゃないじゃないですかべ考える
とまぁ部屋を整理つっていうので有効に使ってみては
開けなかったのではないかなと思っておりますよし
目地ればいいか盲米 cia oh 止め ni
maremare
を飾った
car
それは
その日の夜中ズー
お金を追いかけとってい
me
par
ni
me
いいいいいい
he
脱ぐしていた ee
ni
me
ああああああ